- [Voiceover] Ngozi I think
that's how I would pronounce it,
Ngazi, gozi, needs to send out,
300 wedding invitations,
let me underline that.
300 wedding invitations.
In 1 minute, she can put 6
invitations into envelopes
and apply stamps to them.
It takes her a minimum of 50 seconds
to address each invitation by hand.
If n represents the number of invitations
Ngozi can prepare for
mailing in 180 minutes,
in 180 minutes,
which of the following
inequalities best models
the situation described above.
Over here you have 180
greater than or equal to
something, it's in terms of
and in terms of the number
of invitations.
Is 180 greater than.
This is 300 less than or equal to.
This is 300 less than right over here.
Now remember what our constraint is here,
our constrain is how many can she prepare
in 180 minutes.
How many invitations can
she prepare in 180 minutes
and so it feels like
and I haven't done the math here,
that you're going to want one of them
that deals with the 180
and since you can do it up to 180
that you would want not
just the amount of time
is less than 180 but would have to be
less than or equal to.
180 doesn't just need to be
greater than the amount of time,
it could be greater than or equal to,
as long as this is equal
to 180 we are fine.
So without doing any
math I'm already feeling
that this right over here is going
to be the answer.
The 300, they're getting
this from the fact
that there's 300 wedding invitations.
That there's 300 wedding
invitations to make,
now that is the absolute cap...
That is the absolute cap on the total
number of wedding
invitations that she might
be able to do, but
that's not going to be...
That's not the constraint
that we're talking about,
we're constraining her actual time here.
Let's verify that we feel good about this
and it looks they did
everything in minutes,
so let's do everything in minutes,
so any one envelope...
Let's see in 1 minute she can put
6 invitations into envelopes,
so any 1 invitation,
I guess I could say,
How much time would she spend
sticking it into an envelope
and applying stamps?
Well she's going to spend
a sixth of a minute.
So she's going to spend 1/6 of a minute,
I'm going to do everything in minutes
because these look like they're
in minutes right over here.
A sixth of a minute
putting any one invitation
into an envelope and
putting stamps on them
and then how much time will
she spend writing the address?
Well she's going to spend 50
seconds to write the address
for any one invitation,
but if it's in terms of minutes,
that's 50 out of 60 seconds in a minute.
Or, so we could write this...
We could write this + 5/6...
5/6 of...
+ 5/6 of a minute and I'm really tempted
to add these because they
add up to one to six sixth,
but it doesn't look like
they added them over here,
so I'm going to keep them like this.
This is how much time in
minutes she would spend
on any one...
On any one invitation
and then if she's doing n...
If she's doing n invitations,
well that's...
This is per invitation and
then you multiply by n,
so times n,
this is the total amount
of time she would spend
if she did n invitations,
and so this thing right over here
has to be less than or equal to 180.
So we could write it like this,
we could say less than or equal to 180,
or we could say that 180...
Or we could write that 180
is going to be greater than
or equal to that
and if you distribute the n...
If you distribute the n,
you're going to get this
thing right over here.
You're going to get 180 is
greater than or equal to
n over six...
n/6 plus
plus
5n...
Actually let me write it
that way plus 5 times n...
5 times n over six.
Over 6.
Which is exactly what you have here.
This is really interesting
because just looking
at the choices it actually
jumped out pretty fast
that this was probably going to be
the one that we cared about.